ils ont envahi certains bars et
restaurants lillois depuis près d'une
semaine une quinzaine de commerçants de
la ville nordiste ont adopté cet outil
pour faciliter les contrôles du passé ni
terre à l'initiative du groupement des
commerçants de l'île ce bracelet offre
aux gérants et salariés un contrôle
simplifié et fluidifie le flux des
clients dans les établissements ça
dispositif qui est là pour les aider
donc c'est à dire faciliter le contrôle
du pass à lithaire fluidifier le
contrôle et éviter aux clients d'être
contrôlé plusieurs fois une fois dans
l'établissement il reçoit son bracelet
s'ils sont pas sanitaire est valide et à
partir de là il peut sortir entrée ou
alors se balader dans l'établissement
sans pour tout autant à être content
continuellement contrôler pour savoir si
il a fait le contrôle du pass annie
terre
une opération qui fonctionne près de
20000 bracelets ont déjà été distribués
aux commerçants pour un prix de 5
centimes par pièce plus de dix mille ont
été commandés pour la semaine prochaine
un coup accepté par les restaurateurs
qui apprécient son utilité
ah oui dans la mesure en ce moment
beaucoup de monde chaque soir par la
simplicité dans mon c'est la chose la
plus importante c'est toujours sur les
choses simples et efficaces faut pas
aller chercher vraiment faire les choses
compliquées inventer des choses le pass
est aujourd'hui c'est une obligation et
là on va faire avec
mais ce bracelet fait tout de même débat
une opération du même type avait été
lancée en gironde avant d'être suspendue
pour clarifier les détails d'utilisation
à lille le procédé a été approuvée mais
la préfecture a tenu à préciser un
aspect le bracelet n'a pas vocation à
remplacer le pass sanitaires